he called the game last night with Kevin
Harlan on Westwood one Seahawks in the
49ers how are you Kurt I'm doing really
well how are you guys well I have some
questions here about the San Francisco
49ers let me ask you first what
questions did you get answered or do you
still have with last night's performance
I would say the question I still have is
it's about the quarterback you know
talking about you get Garoppolo and just
saying okay get in a game like that or
you're not running the football and you
have to carry your team and you've got
to make throw after throw I mean you can
put it in overtime and you give them
three straight throws and we go you know
for three there or you know numerous
times you get a ten point lead and
numerous opportunities to kind of drive
the football down to make plays now I
know you had one ball that was in the
hands of a receiver that ends up getting
intercepted but I just didn't think he
was consistent enough and haven't seen
him
consistent enough throwing the football
to think okay when you get into the NFC
playoffs against a good quarterback week
in and week out yes that you'll be able
to beat those guys if other things are
shut down and specifically if the run
game is shut down and so that continues
to be the biggest question for me with
this football team I still think they're
a good football team remember they shot
russell wilson down for the most part
last night you just can't give him that
many opportunities or he's going to come
back and get you but and I'm maybe I'm
making way too much of this but I
wondered about clock management in
overtime when Garoppolo throws three
consecutive passes I guy I have to run
the ball I have to take a little bit off
the clock just so I don't leave Russell
I have to leave that building with a tie
at were skirt and it felt like three
consecutive passes now I've given
Russell Wilson too much time am I am I
making too big a deal absolutely not I
said the same thing on the broadcast is
that obviously you want to get points
and win this game you don't want to
settle for a tie well I'm with you
worst case scenario you have to get a
tie I was really surprised that they
didn't come out with a draw or a screen
something that you can please and as you
said you try to get the yards you try to
get the
going but we're seeing scenarios you can
take 40 seconds off the clock so if you
aren't giving it back so yeah I was 100%
with you is that after the way that game
went back and forth back and forth and
again knowing the guy on the other side
of the field is that you can't give him
three opportunities in overtime and
expect him not to at least get them a
shot at a field goal and so I was I was
disappointed in that part of it too I
thought could have been much better
without it even if you drop it back to
throw it down the field
hey it's not there get a check down get
something that you complete so we can
get this [ __ ] going game on the line
final drive where does Russell Wilson
rank with quarterbacks nowadays that you
would take nowadays I mean he's probably
number two you know and maybe he's moved
into the number one spot I mean Brady
has done it so often so well in the
biggest moment it is hard to go against
him in that moment and I think that's
what separated him and made him the best
ever Russell Wilson is right there in my
opinion I mean he is phenomenal and the
thing about it is that they do a great
job of keeping every game close as well
we talked about the last night there
seven and one in one possession games
this year and that just speaks to who he
is you give him an opportunity down the
stretch never phases him he doesn't you
know usually make mistakes he made the
one mistake last night he thought okay
that one mistake that he normally
doesn't make is going to cost you the
game but he doesn't make mistakes either
with the football it's just phenomenal
what he does and his ability to kind of
live in chaos the craziness going on
around it but it never phases him
talking to Kurt Warner Hall of Famer won
a couple of MVPs work for the NFL
Network and also with Westwood One he
was on the call last night the Seahawks
and the Niners it feels like we have
more good teams in the NFC than the AFC
but the NFC is more wide open than the
AFC who do you think is the best team in
the NFC
best team in the energy I mean it's hard
after this weekend isn't it
you think pretty much everybody would
have said the 49ers for the Saints were
the two best teams in the NFC and then
there's aints go and throw out that
clunker you know Lee San Francisco got
beat by a good team and that is a great
question you know and I always think it
you get talking playoff time and you say
okay who's playing at home when you look
at these teams like the Saints I think
they're going to be really tough to beat
at home even though you know and I know
this weekend you know shows a well maybe
not but I think that team is a complete
team with Drew Brees as a quarterback
San Francisco as I said earlier I'm just
not convinced their quarterback is ready
to go you know swing for swing with the
Aaron Rodgers and Drew Brees is you know
when he has to go two or three games in
the playoffs and the Packers just to me
are kind of up and down and all over the
Minnesota I love Minnesota as a complete
team I'm still not 100% sold on Kirk in
that moment so I'm probably going to
lean towards the Saints I'm curious what
the Ravens learned from last year and
that loss to the Chargers that's helped
them this year with Lamar Jackson like
what is different about the Ravens
approach with Lamar Jackson that makes
it more sustainable for an entire season
and more importantly in the postseason
you know I don't know if they you know
learn anything I mean I think the bottom
line would you look at the Ravens is if
they can play that way an entire game
meaning they don't fall behind
they don't panic they don't struggle
with that you know early and get away
from it I think they can sustain that
and have opportunities to win every game
they can control the clock and run the
football the quarterback is dynamic in
the front game I think what we've seen
in different situations we saw last year
with the Chargers we saw earlier this
year with the Chiefs is when they fall
behind and start to panic and go okay we
can't necessarily run our offense
anymore
that's where they struggle if they can
stay ahead of you and continue to do
what they do and take their shots off a
play-action
I think there's going to be a really
tough out and then if you could get
Lamar Jackson to give you a couple of
those crazy runs or plays throughout the
course of the game they're going to be
really hard but if you can jump up on
them early that's where I've seen them
kind of pull away from that and try to
become something that they're not and
again Lamar has been great
I don't just I don't think he's ready
yet to have to throw 35 times and win
big games well he did say that at the
start of the year that they expected to
throw 30 times and we thought oh my gosh
that's a lot that's the average in the
NFL but it's above average for Lamar
Jackson yeah I think you're right I mean
you know and and I think it's more to
the nature of how they throw a lot of
these teams that are throwing 3540 times
it's amazing how many balls they throw
at the line of scrimmage the nature of
throws for Lamar Jackson is also
play-action and a little bit more down
the field big play type things as
opposed to asking him to be really
efficient on a bunch of of short things
so again it's the nature of how they
play and I'm fascinated to see how this
work come works comes playoff time
because I'm with you I don't think the
AFC is stacked with a bunch of really
good teams or a bunch of really good
defenses but I think I think the Ravens
are going to have a chance to push the
envelope they're come last time yeah I
mean it's interesting now this whole
approach with quarterbacks that but you
did this a lot with the greatest show on
turf I mean you guys were ahead of your
time I think as an offense Marino might
have been most ahead of his time as a
quarterback but the greatest show on
turf you guys were doing these little
paths I mean you could throw it deep but
you're using Marshall Faulk out of the
backfield and you waited for them to
blitz and then you just got rid of it
quickly here is there somebody who's
gonna come up with a defense at some
point Curt who's gonna be able to
minimize the damage with these offenses
now I don't know I mean it's not just
the schemes that we're seeing it's also
the nature of the rule changes and what
you're allowed to do at the line of
scrimmage you know that's the thing is
that you
now we always call these pick or rub
plays that you have now if you're
pressing a guy at the line of scrimmage
if you're within one yard of the line of
scrimmage a receiver can actually go
block you and set a screen for their guy
that's running down the field I mean
it's it's things like that where you go
how do you take away all these quick
passes you have to play press coverage
right you got to get up closer to them
well now we're going to give the offense
an advantage that if you do that we can
run pick plays and I can go block you
and knock you off of your your main
coverage and we can you know free up a
guy down the field so the nature of how
the game is played now and and the rule
changes I think makes it really really
hard to stop you know what these
offenses are doing but you know the
biggest thing is you have to get them
behind the chains at some point in time
you've got to get a negative play either
a sack or a tackle for loss or it's
really really hard to stop people in his
business do you think Julian Edelman is
a Hall of Famer a great question I mean
I think he's right there on the cusp of
it you know what do you want to see like
what is left for him because he's not
gonna have these numbers that compared
to anybody but another Super Bowl
performance yeah yeah I mean I think
that's kind of the crazy thing is when
you when you look at other positions
besides quarterback for me out I don't
know if it's as important to win the
Super Bowl I think you know what he's
got is he's so good in the in the moment
I don't think he gets enough credit for
who he is I probably just need to see in
a four or five or years where he's
healthy and playing at that you know
same level and making those some same
kind of plays because I do appreciate
all the little things that he does in
the way that he plays the game you know
maybe not as flashy as some guys and
probably why we don't have him up there
quite yet but he's been so good at big
moments which I think always should
catapult a guy closer to that Hall of
Fame status that they're just putting up
numbers Julian Edelman at his best
Odell Beckham junior at his best who do
you want as a teammate
um geez uh I mean I'm probably going
Julian Edelman because I just like the
nuances of how and again I think I look
at you know that those little things
that that separate a guy or could make
it easier on a quarterback and I think
he does all of those things so you know
I'm say right now I would say Julian
Edelman until I see more and more
consistency from obj even though he's
you know extremely talented as we all
know I probably go Julian Edelman how do
you shut up a receiver who comes back to
the huddle and tells you he's open I all
you do is you continue to perform that's
what I realized in all my time playing
with great receivers is that you've got
to earn the respect of these guys that
you're doing the right thing with the
football that you're going through your
reads and you're throwing it to the
right guy that's the key and with that
comes success for your football team the
hardest thing is when you're not having
successes you're not complete footballs
and you've got a talented guy that
thinks he's open every play there's not
much you can do to to shut them up
because they're gonna keep coming back
and going hey or not being successful
throw me the football throw it to me I'm
open I'll find a way to make a catch if
you're having success if you're doing
the right thing with the football and
you're throwing it to the open guy I
think every great receivers realizes
okay I can't really say anything because
he's playing good football and we're
playing good football even if I'm not
touching it you consider yourself more
of a rammer Cardinal you know it's a
great question and I would probably say
a cargo as strange as that is with as
much success and you know maybe you know
the best years of my career being with
the Rams but I think a lot of it has to
do with just where I ended the fact that
you know I ended with the Cardinals I'm
still more connected with the team and
the front office and stuff there I still
live in Arizona you know again hard to
say cuz I love both organizations and
both of them were you know about equal
for my career I would probably say a
little bit more with the Cardinals good
to visit with you as always Curt love
putting you on the spot there you know
it's like you know I'm like that Blitzer
you don't see I just you know trying to
be sneaky I see
all right that's Kurt Warner for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]